okay some breaking news out of iran now
three ships
are on fire at their southern bashar
port it's the latest
in a series of explosions and fires to
hit iran in recent weeks
let's go live to assad big in tehran i
said what more do we know about what's
happening
well what we know so far is that this is
taking place at a vessel factory which
holds seven
ships have been burnt so far that's the
latest that we have
and we've also been told that the fire
is under control it's not extinguished
firefighters are on the scene
and the head of the crisis management uh
in the bashar province has said
that there's been no casualties but they
don't know the cause or the extent
of the damage so far he said that high
winds and flammable materials haven't
helped the situation and the reason that
this incident
has gained attention is because there is
also a nuclear power plant
in bashar and again there's been a
series of incidents over the last few
weeks
that have increased suspicions we had a
fire here in tehran at a clinic
where there were casualties we've had an
explosion at parchin which is to the
east of tehran at the suspected missile
site
and of course at the main nuclear
facility in the tans there was a fire
there
now what was behind that well we just
don't know but there have been reports
by foreign media
that the the natanz especially was an
act of sabotage kind of by the israelis
now we put that to the foreign ministry
spokesman abbas musavi the other day and
he
said he wouldn't deny or confirm
anything until the investigation
was over and the findings released now
that's what we've been hearing
from iranian officials that an
investigation is underway
and the findings will be released and if
it's found that a foreign power has been
involved in any incident
iran will have to retaliate and carry
out a response
but again he did indicate that security
had been
increased at some sites but this could
just be because of the high temperatures
the country
is experiencing it could also be that
iran isn't the sanctions and
the and is dependent on its domestic
infrastructure
for its maintenance repair and safety of
these
sites but again iran is very protective
over incidents that take place near
military or at military and nuclear
facilities and when the officials do
speak we hear very little
or they're very reserved but again
suspicions are high currently
just because of the number of incidents
that have taken place over the last few
weeks
that's asset bank bringing this update
from tehran
i said thank you very much as always